about a year ago rogue nine who's a
rainbow six siege youtuber
was accused of harassment by a ubisoft
employee
he was blacklisted from ever working
with ubisoft again and the popular siege
podcast that he co-hosted
was ultimately cancelled but now almost
a year
later rogue 9 says that those
allegations were all
a lie and that this is just a giant
cover-up by another ubisoft employee
all right in case you somehow forgot
we're putting out new youtube videos
all the time we want to know what you
guys want to see what stories you want
covered on don't at me
so like the video drop us a comment and
don't forget to subscribe to the
channel okay now back to the story okay
we got all sorts of allegations to get
through but this story
starts with the hot breech podcast which
rogue nine co-hosted alongside
other siege youtubers get flanked and
prodigio pete and as far as siege
specific podcasts go it was pretty
popular
what is up everybody welcome to a very
special episode of the hot breech
podcast back in october of 2019 the hot
breech guys were invited by ubisoft down
to a balancing workshop that was being
hosted in barcelona
the idea was that they would come
experience what the workshop had to say
and then record a podcast live in
barcelona the reality is this barcelona
trip was a disaster for everyone
involved and it actually led to the end
of the hot breech podcast
because the very next day she told all
of her montreal-based colleagues and
many of the barcelona-based ones
that i'd been harassing her and that i
made her feel quote
very uncomfortable and unsurprisingly
making such a serious accusation against
me
turned an awkward situation into a
complete
nightmare now almost a year after the
trip
rogue9 recently put out a video talking
about the harassment allegations made
against him
and how the barcelona trip played a role
in ultimately getting him blacklisted by
ubisoft
i will be sharing a story of how i was
physically threatened at a rainbow six
event by a ubisoft staff member who was
drunk off his face
as well as details of defamation and
match fixing by another
in the video he also accuses two siege
community developers
of abusing their position threatening
him and even allegedly
match fixing a charity creator show
match we'll get to those accusations in
a little bit but first
let's start with the harassment
allegations in this barcelona trip
according to rogue nine in the months
leading up to the barcelona trip
he struck up a conversation with a
ubisoft employee over dms
that quote got a bit personal implying
that things were moving towards a
romantic relationship
last year between august and october
things became a bit personal between a
ubisoft employee
and me i'm not going to go into too much
detail here but it is important to
briefly touch on this
luckily almost all of our communications
were over twitter dms and i still have
the entire thread
to prove exactly what happened these
messages prove
that she made the first advances and
that she repeatedly
encouraged me to keep in touch with her
eventually rogue 9
says that the woman he was talking to
clarified the situation
there wasn't going to be a romantic
partnership and while he felt led on
and was hurt and told her as much
apparently according to him
the whole thing was chalked up to a
giant misunderstanding now
the woman rogue 9 was talking to was the
same woman that was going to be running
the upcoming barcelona balancing event
which remember the hot breech guys were
invited to and while rogue says that the
barcelona trip was
awkward but ultimately harmless i've had
multiple sources tell me a different
story
and sadly all of this happened right
before a week-long balancing workshop at
ubisoft's barcelona offices
which she had organized and that i had
committed to taking part in many months
earlier
from what i was told and how get flank
shares his perspective in a recent video
he uploaded
rogue nine took the rejection pretty
personally
and it ruined the entire trip for the
hot breech team
once we arrived it was evident from like
day one that it was going to be an issue
like
i would say that it was awkward
from the get-go there were awkward
dinners with everyone involved
rogue's co-hosts did their best to
distract him get flank
says that rogue tried to confront her
about the situation
which rogue disputes the point is this
situation was
terrible for everyone involved
everything went from like
awkward on the trip to just like
dysfunction like it was
the the tension was unbearable and it
was
so awful okay um
it got to the point where like she very
clearly
like you had to like organize the the
taxis that we took from the studio and
back like
you had to make sure that they weren't
in the same taxi and stuff like that
like
it was it was awful like it was it
consumed the entire trip it went from
rogue being consumed by it to just
putting a dark cloud over everything
um over the course of that entire trip i
never
saw her do anything that i felt was
unprofessional
i never saw anything from any ubisoft
employee on that trip that i
felt was unprofessional and then the day
the podcast was set to record
with the employee featured as a
prominent guest rogue-9
allegedly tried to veto her because he
was still upset about the entire
situation while they managed to get
through the episode get flank says that
rogue nine's behavior on the trip
caused him and prodigio pete to actually
end the hot breech podcast
after the barcelona episode and to stop
working with rogue nine all together
we basically decide at that point that
we don't want to work with rogue anymore
and not long after that rogue nine
received the email from ubisoft saying
that they were
banning him from ever working with
ubisoft again because of these alleged
harassment
allegations quote due to your conduct
during the operator balancing sprint
workshop in barcelona spain
we regret to inform you that ubisoft
will no longer be working with you
moving forward
this includes future activations such as
the london event
taking place on october 24th we have and
always will
value the content you have created over
the years that said
we cannot and will not accept behavior
directed towards ubisoft's staff that is
disrespectful
dismissive or rude end quote shortly
after get flank put out his video
sharing his perspective on the barcelona
balancing trip rogue 9 posted another
twit longer basically disputing a lot of
the events that get flank says happened
at this point
it's become a bit of a he said he said
and the crazy thing about this situation
is that ubisoft reached out to me with a
statement long before i ever asked for
comment which to me
says that they're taking this very
seriously quote the work of content
creators is critical to the health and
integrity of our communities
and our relationship with these creators
is built on mutual respect and
professionalism
if these principles are not respected
ubisoft will take action we deem
appropriate in order to protect our
employees
partners in the wider community end
quote okay so
that wraps up the barcelona and
harassment allegations
but we're not done with everything yet
now on top of stating that the
harassment accusations are a lie
rogue 9 also makes allegations to former
siege community developers justin kruger
and craig robinson
who goes by appie online and that's how
i'll be referring to him from now on
basically these two guys were largely
responsible for working with siege
content creators whether at events
or online having a community development
team is pretty typical
they act as a buffer between the
developer and the rest of the community
while also working with content creators
and as far as siege goes
justin and craig were the go-to guys for
this type of stuff now
rogue nine alleges that at an after
party for the siege 2019 invitational
justin kruger acted in a drunken and
threatening manner towards him
after rogue nine congratulated justin on
a recent promotion
i too clapped justin on the shoulder
congratulated him on his new role wished
him
all the best and told him that the
entire siege community would miss him
in response i got an angry scowl
he threw his head back stuck out his
chin and waved his hand in my face in a
gesture that was basically telling me to
[ __ ] off
while saying yeah right then he brought
his hands down and briefly kept both of
his fists clenched by his side
while standing in front of me still
scowling with his chin up
in a clearly threatening manner he also
accuses justin and eppie but primarily
epi of gatekeeping the siege content
creator community
giving streamer charms to their friends
who didn't meet the criteria
and overall just playing favorites the
godly noob posted similar accusations of
gatekeeping playing favorites on twitter
which lines up to what multiple sources
have told me
one example is effie allegedly giving a
streamer charm to a content creator
named punjistic
despite the fact that he didn't meet the
criteria and only because they were
friends
and basically in order to get a streamer
charm you need to hit certain streaming
milestones like
stream 20 hours of siege per month have
350 plus concurrent viewers and so on
and streamer charms are
huge for creator growth because the only
way to get a charm
in game is by subscribing to a creator's
twitch channel multiple sources have
told me that even if you are a
well-known content creator
if for some reason justin or eppy didn't
like you or they had a friend that they
could work with instead
you'd be left out in the cold now i know
these allegations seem like
petty beeps with content creators who
feel like they're not getting enough
shine
but this is actually a potential problem
trust plays a huge role between the
community
development team and the content
creators if the content creators can't
trust you or feel like you aren't being
honest why would they want to make
content
for your game and if they don't want to
create content around your game well
that's a huge [ __ ] problem because
who watches the stuff they make the
community the people
buying the battle passes and the skins
and the streamer charms
basically the entire lifeblood of your
product now rogue's final allegation
against eppie is the most egregious
but also the hardest to prove i know for
a fact
that during his time on the rainbow six
com dev team
craig robinson engaged in match fixing
of content creator show matches
he openly sabotaged teams and there are
even allegations that he ordered teams
to throw
matches rogue 9 alleges that somehow
eppy
fixed a twitch rival's creator show
match in 2019
in order to get his friends more money
it was supposed to be a 50 000
charity show match with 40 grand going
to the winning teams charity of choice
10 grand going to the losers team
charity of choice but on top of that the
creators that participated were paid to
be there and allegedly
the winning players from the winning
team were paid an extra 2500
each rogue 9 alleges that eppy stacked
the winning team with his
friends and the losing team had two
players who had never played siege
before i've spoken with people who were
at the event and they say that yes the
format was weird as in why are content
creators being paid to play in a charity
show match
and yes the winning team was stacked but
nobody i spoke to
says that eppie deliberately fixed the
match rogue 9 says that he is definitive
proof that eppie did
fix this content creator match but at
this point he hasn't made that evidence
public
all of this brings us to now where rogue
9 is still blacklisted from working with
ubisoft almost a year after the
barcelona trip he says that he can't get
a single ubisoft employee to speak with
him
explicitly stating that eppie somehow
managed to coerce
hundreds of ubisoft employees into
silence all because eppy is close
friends with the woman who made the
harassment allegations in the first
place i reached out to various contacts
on several occasions with the simple
goal of clearing my name
that's all i wanted the entire barcelona
situation
honestly seems like a giant
miscommunication that was handled poorly
by
everyone involved including rogue nine
sure being
blacklisted over something like this
does seem a tad harsh
but ultimately that's ubisoft's call to
make
and while obviously the most popular
content creators are always going to get
the most attention from the pr
teams this pattern of favoritism and
gatekeeping within the siege community
is concerning and i do hope that ubisoft
is taking those allegations seriously
for all you youngsters i'd
yes this is nothing but teen angst
drama [ __ ] but holy [ __ ] is it some
of the best teenage drama [ __ ]
that you'll find ever on tv okay
and am i being hyperbolic here of course
i am